lula est à genève depuis jeudi l'ancien
président du brésil demande à l'onu de
rétablir la vérité
le fondateur du parti des travailleurs a
saisi le comité des droits de l'homme
onusien en 2016 objectif ouvrir une
enquête contre brasilia après sa
condamnation pour corruption et
blanchiment d'argent
l'ex-chef d'état âgé de 74 ans a été
accueilli par ses soutiens en suisse
écoutez nous avons une honte du
président en ce moment au brésil en
fashion et ici nous avons le vrai
président qui a été un péché d'être dans
les urnes nous sommes là pour ça pour la
justice justice soit faite et que 2022
lula soit à nouveau vers les urnes
c'était important pour moi de pouvoir
être là ce soir et de pouvoir montrer
que des brésiliens dans le monde entier
ici à genève aussi soutiennent ou là
aujourd'hui il n'est plus en prison mais
il n'est pas encore innocenté et voilà
c'est le moment il va je pense parler
devant la presse qu'il défende sa
position et puis qu'ils puissent à
prouver son innocence et qu'elle soit
reconnu